>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, D.C.
>> Hey, how did you distinguish what
was accurate and what was not accurate?
>> You know, it comes with time.
Do you know people who cook?
Who are good cooks?
>> Yes.
>> And you know how like they can say
a pinch of this and a pinch of that
and you just wonder how did you learn that?
In the beginning, they used to
read a recipe and follow it.
So it's just like that.
You just develop or imagine.
In athletics, I think, there's a point
I guess when Michael Jordan didn't have
to think about a layup or something.
So I think it's just you work muscles
enough and then your hunch gets better.
The more you read, the more you know.
Also too, you have to have
expert people to go to.
People to go to whom you trust.
For example, if I'm doing something
on Civil War reconstruction,
I'm going to mispronounce his name, but one of
my to go guys is Eric Foner because I found,
not that's he's infallible but I found
in time that he's very reasonable.
And to me, he seems like he
wants to tell the true story.
I mean, he doesn't try to make
someone look better than they are.
Like his take on Lincoln, he says, "Look, a
lot of people like to read him from the back,"
in saying in other words
because they're uncomfortable
with certain positions that he took in life.
So I found him to be very honest and balanced.
So I tended to go to him when I was
working my book on "The New Deal.
FDR's Alphabet Soup."
I had the book "Freedom from Fear"
by -- I'm going to mess up his name.
His last name is Kennedy.
So I said to a friend of mine who
teaches history at Howard, I said,
"Is this a good," He said, "Oh yeah.
I studied with him in college.
He's good."
So that's the other thing too, is I
have friends who are trained historians
that sometimes I can go to and say, "Is this
a good source," or "Who should I read to get,"
and also too, see I get like a dog
with a bone when I'm on a project.
So D.C. Archives, you know, I
email people and call people,
and that's what I always remind young scholars
to do is that people at libraries, at archives,
at all these institutions,
they live to help people.
As long as they know that you're not trifling
and you don't just want to
get somebody to do your work.
So I don't know.
So I'll say, "Well, do you
have a photo of this,"
or "Do you know anything about this," you know?
Such and such.
So I just pursue experts and
trying to get them to help me.
And most of the time, I'm pretty successful
because I was always say, even when checkout,
"Here's my website," so they
can see that I'm legitimate.
And people sometimes write me and
say, "Do you know such and such
with [inaudible] known this person."
I say, "Well I think probably so
because blah, blah, blah, blah."
You know?
>> Yes.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.